Magna Carta means great charter in
English it was drawn up in 1215 as the
first contract between a monarch and
their subjects who agreed that no one
not even the king was above the law it
began as a peace treaty between King
John and powerful landowners or Barons
who had captured London and though the
peace lasted just a few months when King
John died his son Henry rewrote the
Charter several times despite the
changes three clauses are still part of
English law today the rights of the
church freedom for London and other
towns the right to justice and a fair
trial principles which were echoed many
centuries later in the United States the
United Nations and in Europe